hi I'm Eric Betsy
hi and I'm Harold Hess and like to
present today a little story behind a
new kind of microscope that we involved
invented which can take resolution from
normal step microscope resolution to
super resolution and also give you a
little story behind how we came to the
idea and it came to pass so Harold and I
have been friends for pretty much over
20 years I first met him when I went to
Bell Labs and joined him in the
semiconductor physics research
department I went to Bell to continue my
work from my graduate thesis on the
development of the first super
resolution optical microscope called the
near-field optical microscope with that
microscope you were able to for example
on fixed cells go from resolution like
this in the conventional sense to what
you see here in the near-field sense but
probably what's most germane for this
talk is with the microscope I was also
able to see for the first time single
molecules under ambient conditions and
make extended observations and imaging
of these molecules with a resolution
down or not a resolution but a
localization precision down to about 12
nanometers yeah meanwhile I was also at
Bell Labs and I was focusing on scan
probe microscopy but particularly at low
temperatures and this was an exciting
field at the time I was trying a few
different variations of scan probe
microscopes to sense tunneling current
magnetic field or electrical field and
actually had a lot of fun with that
but sooner or later Eric and I decided
to join forces and we combined his near
field technology which sort of puts
light in a very small diffractive area
together with my low-temperature system
and we focused initially on a system
called quantum wells which where you
have these little luminescent centers
which are supposed to glow another way
to represent that data is with this
little block that you see right here
where you see X&Y
down here which is real space and the
vertical scale up here is now spectral
now so you can see that the spreading
the data out inspect in the spectral
dimension really helps us to see these
individual luminescent centers and was
key to this particular experiment so
while I had a lot of fun with Harold and
doing my other experiments with near
width near field while I was a bell
eventually I got pretty fed up with the
whole thing in part because of the
physical limitations of the near-field
technique and in part because it
engendered a really big academic
bandwagon with many people getting into
it and the hike greatly exceeding the
reality and I got to the point where I
said you know I really want to try
something new I'm really sick of the
whole structure of academic science and
so I laughed and did my first midlife
crisis and while I was thinking a light
bulb popped on and I thought you could
actually combine the ideas of my single
molecule experiment with the quantum
well experiment that Harold and I did to
potentially create a molecular
resolution optical microscope so the
idea would be consider a bunch of
molecules here which are initially not
resolved because they're bunch of fuzzy
spots overlap but again if they have
some feature by which they differ from
one another that you can identify like
they glow with different colors or they
blank or they have different
polarizations or whatever then if you
measure those those parameters you can
isolate the molecules just like we did
with the quanta the exit on
recombination sites you can isolate
these points in this multi-dimensional
space and once they're isolated then you
can find the Centers of these fuzzy
balls to much better than the diameter
of the fuzzy balls like I did in the
near field technique and then you're
able to project those Center positions
back to spatial coordinates and
basically get a super resolution map of
where all the molecules are located so
to do that with the technology the time
is going to be very difficult because to
be able to see many molecules in one
diffraction-limited region was going to
require very high resolution in that
third dimension you might be able to do
it spectrally but it would have been a
hero experiment and I was pretty fed up
with with
things at that time so I went on a
completely different tack and started to
work from my dad's machine tool company
in Michigan actually a year or two later
I also left Bell Laboratories I sort of
felt the field of scan probe microscopy
was maturing and I thought there were
maybe other larger opportunities
particularly in these small little
startups which were forming out in
California and at that point I joined
this company called faze metrics which
does test and measurement equipment for
the hard disk drive industry and I
thought some of my nanotechnology
imaging experience could both benefit
and also give new ideas for myself so
these are some sample machines which
check disks or read/write heads that
company later on got bought out by
another one KLA ten cord so that was all
a lot of fun and I even had the
opportunity to explore new concepts and
actually came up with a nice idea which
was got funding and was ready to launch
but it was going to be launched in San
Jose and I was faced with a decision
either move joined this little project
or go back to a bit more research mode
and I was talking with Eric and I
decided in the end that it would be fun
to take the more adventuresome path and
search for something new but it wasn't
quite clear what so while I was doing my
searching I was trying to think of where
I wanted to go and what I wanted to do
to get back into perhaps science because
although I learned after seven years of
my dad's company a that I'm a really bad
salesman but be that I didn't like the
academic structure of science but I
really loved the science itself and so I
started thinking about different ideas
and at the same time yeah I was also
contemplating along with Eric and we
actually had many trips to national
parks trying to figure out where are the
opportunities in science were the new
challenges where the untrodden paths and
we sort of were overcome sometimes with
a just a feeling of insignificance
compared to the vastness of what's out
there
so eventually although I didn't want to
do microscopy I wanted to try something
new and different
in 2003 I first read a paper about green
fluorescent protein which of course has
sense even by that time is in the
process of completely transforming cell
biology in many other fields of biology
and honest-to-goodness I was probably
the last man on earth to learn about GFP
but I immediately realized that this
would be transformative not only to
biology but to biological microscopy
because what we might be able to do with
it
so in my job searching I had also
contacted a lot of other friends and one
of the places which I visited was
Tallahassee Florida and there I thought
might be an interesting place to see
whether Eric's idea could possibly fly
and particularly at that place there's a
laboratory called a magnet laboratory
where he had networking colleagues and
one person there Michael Davidson was
remarkable he actually has a wonderful
website very comprehensive and was
writing you know very important reviews
of all the major developments in the
field in particular while we're there he
pointed out there's not just the green
fluorescent protein there a whole new
class of optical highlighters or
photoactivatable PA FPS those proteins
fluorescent proteins are essentially
dark or maybe often a different spectral
range and when you normally look at it
you see nothing but if you shine blue
light you can effectively turn them on
and this is magical so as soon as Harold
and I left Tallahassee it became obvious
to us that this was really the missing
link to make that idea that I had
published after I first left Bell work
so the thought is is rather than bathing
the entire specimen with blue light
until it all glows is just turn on the
blue or purple light for a very brief
period of time so only a few molecules
turn on at once then since they're
isolated from one another we can find
their centers and plot those then they
burn out and bleach and we turn on a new
set of molecules by pulsing the light on
again and repeat this process for many
frames until you determine the
ordinance of every molecule inside of
the sample so instead of that original
quantum well experiment where we
separated the the exit on recombination
sites in terms of XY and wavelength now
it's in terms of XY and time so just in
case you didn't quite get the arocs
explanation let me just restate it in
plain English basically scoot over just
a little bit right there you see a lot
of molecules and they're normally very
densely packed impossible to resolve
them clearly but if you put in a little
bit of blue light you can turn on a very
small subset and they're far enough
apart that you can see each one blow
independently localize its center and
you repeat this until you exhaust all of
the molecules and you can then resolve
the complete super-resolution image
whereas if they all glowed at once you
would just see a massive blur that looks
like this so once we realized that this
was possible we immediately set off to a
quiet place Sedona Arizona and wrote up
our ideas in a patent and started
scheming how can we make this microscope
happen fast it was an idea which was
very ripe and potentially very powerful
at the time and so within about a month
or two we were actually out in my living
room assembling collecting parts and
assembling the microscope itself we were
able to sort by past the complete
funding procedure or venture capital and
were able to move at lightning speed so
within literally a few months December
2005 use this was existing in the living
room but the one missing piece still was
as physicists we didn't know the first
thing about how to do real biology so we
need to collaborate with good biologists
so I had been set to give an interview
talk at NIH about the same time and so
when I was there I begged to be able to
speak to Jennifer Lippincott Schwartz
and George Patterson who were the
inventors of the original photo
activated GFP and so we include the man
on what the idea was swor them to
secrecy and asked them if they wanted to
collaborate and they were very receptive
and very helpful and Jennifer
offered us not only your help but lab
space and some equipment money and so
forth and so soon we were off and
running not just with the instrument
from Harold's lab but we were able to
part that to to Bethesda and get started
very quickly so here again is Harold's
movie but now shown with real data so
maybe you'll finally really understand
it so the frame on the Left shows
single-molecule frames from lysosomes
that have been cut through to a very
thin section and then turning on the
blue light very briefly in small bursts
to turn on small amounts of molecules
which are clearly isolated from one
another
if you summed up all of those frames you
get the frame in the middle which then
represents what you would see in a
normal optical microscope but if instead
you find the centres of all of those
molecules from the frames at the left
and plot them over on the right then you
end up getting a super resolution image
you can see that a little bit better
here where you see in the middle on the
left a diffraction-limited image of
these lysosomes and on the right then
the Palm image of the lysosomes and I
really appreciate exactly how much the
resolution is improved if you zoom in
here you go from this type of resolution
here to this type of resolution here so
this became the basis of our first palm
science paper back in 2006 so I thought
it would conclude by just trying to put
together some some thoughts which I
think we're actually very helpful for us
and in succeeding I think both of us
have a little bit of a version for doing
the mainstream and so we actively sought
out areas which were not very
fashionable at all and try to avoid
those areas that you know very
explicitly I think for both of us is
actually very valuable to seek out a
diversity of experiences we sort of
bounced through multiple fields and just
experiencing new problem sets from the
outside not just from the immediate
research but from the outside I think
was very helpful and actually very very
liberating for us and made the whole
thing a lot of
and just to reiterate what Harold just
said I think one of the key lessons is
to not necessarily jump on those
bandwagons like I said but forge your
own path okay most people who are
probably looking at this video have been
in science for a while and if you're a
young guy you're trying to figure out
how you're going to what you're going to
really do for your career you've
probably invested a lot of time and
effort to get to this point I think it's
a mistake too many people make to try to
go the safe route from a funding
perspective and whatever to go into the
fields that are already fairly mature
the thing to do is to really try in my
opinion to strike your own path but you
have to really have the courage of your
convictions to tune out what other
people are saying and to not be upset
when you don't get the first grant or to
and and to try to be a little bit scared
because the adrenaline pump also helps
in being productive but really whatever
you do you should do the thing that you
love doing because nothing worthwhile
was ever done without passion
you